Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
¿Por qué los gatos hacen eso?
Son lindos, son amables;
según las 26 000 millones de vistas de
más de 2 millones de videos de YouTube
donde saltan,
rebotan,
trepan,
se agazapan,
acechan,
arañan,
corretean
y ronronean,
una cosa es cierta:
Los gatos son muy entretenidos.
Estos comportamientos felinos
un tanto extraños,
divertidos y desconcertantes,
nos plantean la pregunta:
"¿Por qué los gatos hacen eso?"
Los gatos eran depredadores solitarios
de animales más pequeños
y eran presa de carnívoros más grandes.
Para el depredador y la presa,
la supervivencia de su especie dependía
de comportamientos instintivos cruciales
que aún hoy vemos en los gatos
silvestres y domésticos.
Mientras las acciones del gato doméstico
Grizmo pueden parecer desconcertantes,
en la naturaleza,
estos mismos comportamientos
que los gatos desarrollaron naturalmente
durante millones de años,
harían de Grizmo un súper gato.
La singular estructura muscular
y el agudo equilibrio del gato
le permiten subir a miradores altos
para estudiar su territorio
y divisar sus presas en la naturaleza.
Hoy en día Grizmo no necesita
estas habilidades
para cazar y llevar la cena
a su plato de comida,
pero instintivamente, evolucionó
para ver la sala de estar
desde arriba de la estantería.
Como depredadores, los gatos son
oportunistas y cazan si hay presas.
Como la mayoría de sus
presas son pequeñas,
los gatos silvestres tenían que
comer muchas veces al día,
y acechar, abalanzarse, atacar
y matar para alimentarse.
Por eso, Grizmo prefiere perseguir
y saltar sobre los juguetes pequeños
y comer pequeñas comidas
durante el día y por la noche.
Las pequeñas presas suelen ocultarse
en espacios diminutos en la naturaleza
y por eso Grizmo tiene tendencia
a meterse en recipientes y aberturas
porque se siente atraído
por la misma curiosidad
que le ayudó a asegurar la continuación
de su especie durante millones de años.
En la naturaleza necesitan garras afiladas
para escalar, cazar y defenderse.
Afilar sus garras en superficies cercanas
las mantiene acondicionadas y listas,
le ayuda a estirar los músculos
de la espalda y de las piernas
y a aliviar algo de estrés, también.
Por eso no es que Grizmo odie el sofá,
la silla,
la otomana,
las almohadas,
las cortinas
y todo lo demás de su entorno.
El gato rasga esas cosas en pedazos para
mantener sus garras en plena forma
porque es exactamente lo que hacían
sus antepasados para sobrevivir.
Como animales que fueron depredados,
evolucionaron para no ser atrapados
y, en la naturaleza, prosperaron los gatos
que mejor evitaron a sus depredadores.
Así que hoy en tu casa,
Grizmo es experto en apretujarse
en espacios pequeños
y esconderse en lugares
no convencionales.
También explica por qué prefiere una
caja de arena limpia y libre de olores.
Pues es menos probable que delate
su ubicación a cualquier depredador
que pueda husmear en las inmediaciones.
Teniendo en cuenta todo
lo que sabemos de los gatos,
parece que uno de sus
comportamientos predominantes
es aún uno de los más misteriosos.
Los gatos pueden ronronear
por varias razones:
por felicidad,
por estrés
y por hambre.
Pero, curiosamente,
la frecuencia de sus ronroneos,
entre 25 y 150 Hertz,
está en un rango que puede promover
la regeneración de tejidos.
Si bien el ronroneo de Grizmo es
un excelente compañero de siesta,
es posible que el ronroneo
cure sus músculos y huesos,
y quizá incluso los tuyos también.
Lo desarrollaron con el tiempo
como depredadores solitarios
que cazaban y mataban para comer
mientras la presa sigilosa se ocultaba
y escapaba para sobrevivir.
Los gatos conservan muchos
de estos instintos hoy
que les permitieron prosperar en la
naturaleza durante millones de años.
Esto explica parte de sus comportamientos
aparentemente extraños.
Para ellos, nuestras casas son sus selvas.
Pero si este es el caso,
ante los ojos del gato,
¿quiénes somos nosotros?
¿Gatos grandes, mudos, sin pelo que
compiten con ellos por los recursos?
¿Predadores muy tontos a los que
pueden burlar todos los días?
O quizá piensan que somos la presa.